[Música]
la Unión Europea intenta acercarse a
China y en ese contexto cuatro líderes
del viejo continente han viajado a
Beijing los últimos en ir fueron el
presidente francés Emmanuel macón y la
presidenta de la comisión europea Úrsula
Under Legend de un lado Bruselas Quiere
afianzar sus relaciones comerciales con
la segunda economía más grande del mundo
y alentar a China a que utilice su
cercanía con Rusia para mediar en la
guerra en Ucrania pero del otro lado hay
reticencia por el cambio del orden
mundial que quiere Beijing y por las
denuncias de que el gobierno chino ha
cometido violaciones de derechos humanos
y es uno de los mayores contaminadores
en materia de medio ambiente una
disyuntiva que Es evidente cuando justo
después de negociar con los europeos el
presidente envió a sus tropas a
presionar a Taiwán con ejercicios
militares Pero antes de profundizar en
estas dos caras de la moneda veamos un
repaso en el siguiente informe de lo que
ocurrió durante la visita de mahón y
bunder Legend a China
relaciones económicas y guerra en
Ucrania los dos focos de los encuentros
entre Emanuel macron Úrsula Wonder
Legends en Beijing Francia intenta
aprovechar las buenas relaciones entre
China y Rusia Unidos por su interés en
acabar con la hegemonía de Estados
Unidos para encontrar una salida
pacífica a la invasión rusa de
ucraniana
estamos comprometidos y sé que ustedes
también con la carta de Naciones Unidas
y con los textos vigentes en materia
nuclear
y sé que puedo contar con ustedes bajo
los dos principios que mencioné para
hacer que Rusia entre en razón y reunir
a todo el mundo en la mesa de
negociación
el kremlin ya ha rechazado un diálogo a
corto plazo pero mientras ni macron Y si
logren que Putin y selensky se sienten
en la mesa de negociación el objetivo es
evitar la escalada nuclear
debemos respetar nuestro solemne
compromiso de no usar armas nucleares y
de no recurrir a la guerra nuclear y
reanudar las conversaciones de paz
Cuando sea posible la presidenta de la
comisión europea fue más dura en sus
palabras expresó preocupación por los
derechos humanos en el país y pidió
responsabilidad a China como miembro del
Consejo de Seguridad de la ONU
alineándose con las advertencias
repetidas por Washington
armar al agresor es una Clara violación
del derecho internacional es el agresor
y nunca debe ser armado Y eso dañaría
significativamente la relación entre la
Unión Europea y china
en el ámbito económico y en palabras del
presidente francés Europa quiere
comerciar con china pero como hace
Beijing tiene que ser capaz de
protegerse macron llegó al gigante
asiático acompañado de más de 50
empresarios franceses la aeronáutica
europea airbus o la empresa Estatal de
energía francesa odef son algunas de las
compañías que en el marco de este viaje
han firmado nuevos acuerdos con sus
chinos vemos como entonces este viaje
muestra las intenciones políticas y
comerciales que tiene la Unión Europea
para acercarse a China Pero qué tan
dependiente es Bruselas de Beijing y que
quiere china a cambio se desmarcarán los
europeos de su relación con Estados
Unidos para unirse más a los chinos lo
veremos en este debate de France 24 y
para analizar todos estos temas
invitamos a Bruno vinetti investigador
para diálogo interamericano sobre China
y quien se encuentra en Londres y desde
mar del plata en Argentina nos acompaña
Patricio yuston director de diagnóstico
político observatorio chino argentino
para nuestros televidentes les
recordamos
les recordamos que también hacen parte
de este debate dejen sus comentarios y
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
nos encuentran en Twitter Facebook e
Instagram como arroba
franz24-raya al piso es y pueden
comentar con la etiqueta numeral el
debate f24 a mí me encuentran en todas
las redes sociales como arroba María cl
agui no olviden que todos los contenidos
de nuestro programa están disponibles en
Apple podcast Spotify deezer y TuneIn
Ahora sí quiero de nuevo darle la
bienvenida a Bruno vinetti y a Patricio
yuu comenzando con Bruno Gracias por
estar con nosotros estábamos viendo
primero la cara dura de china con los
ejercicios militares que han realizado
durante tres días en el estrecho de
Taiwán después de que la presidenta
taiwanesa
y su paso por Estados Unidos donde se
reunió con Kevin mccarthy el presidente
de la cámara de representantes Usted
cree que La amenaza militar de China
frente a Taiwán cambia en algo o no las
relaciones de Beijing con Estados Unidos
con Estados Unidos definitivamente
estamos en una etapa de tensión
geopolítica que es difícil encontrarle
precedentes después de final de la
Guerra Fría el tema es Cuál es la
posición de Europa en en esta
confrontación y me parece que la idea
del presidente macron en su visita es
establecer una posición europea Autónoma
de los Estados Unidos en un momento como
decías muy desafiantes sobre todo por la
guerra en Ucrania la guerra en Ucrania
de alguna manera acercó a Europa a los
Estados Unidos reforzó y le dio un nuevo
sentido a la otan y en ese contexto para
Europa y para Francia en particular
manejar este aumento de las tensiones
entre Estados Unidos y China alrededor
de Taiwán va a ser muy muy complejo
y precisamente Esta complejidad es la
que mostró la visita de mahón y Wonder
Legends y sobre todo ellos todos
tuvieron posturas diferentes mientras
macron decía que Europa debe reducir su
dependencia de Estados Unidos y evitar
por ejemplo confrontaciones en Taiwán
Wonder lakey Tuvo una posición más dura
y afirmó que la fuerza para cambiar el
estatus de La Isla es inaceptable y que
la estabilidad en el estrecho de Taiwán
es muy importante Patricio bienvenido y
cuéntenos Qué posturas hay dentro de la
Unión Europea y si estas posiciones de
macrón y bonder Legend nos muestran una
división al respecto
Bueno yo creo que son dos niveles de lo
mismo de la misma cosa
wonderlay en representando la postura
política histórica de la Unión Europea
haciendo mucho énfasis en cuestiones
territoriales el caso de Taiwán
cuestiones de derechos humanos y macron
un presidente que debe actuar con
pragmatismo como le pasó hace unas
semanas atrás a shorts el canciller
Alemán que también estuvo en China
Sánchez que también estuvo en China
cuando llegan Cuando uno llega a Beijing
Tiene que dejar de lado un montón de
discursos que en las tribunas de la
Unión Europea de los Estados Unidos uno
expresa como mandatario y ahí hay que
negociar con el principal socio o
segundo tercero según el caso el país
que tomemos pero la importancia de china
en lo económico es muy importante lo va
a seguir siendo entonces en esta nueva
autonomía que Bruno mencionaba o esta
búsqueda de cierta autonomía que que
busca la Unión Europea hay que balancear
lo económico con lo político entonces
estas dificultades
estuvieron presentes en esta gira y las
vamos a seguir viendo en futuras visitas
de mandatarios europeos y para mirar más
esta autonomía bajo la lupa de la
dependencia económica que puede llegar a
tener Europa de China Le quiero
preguntar a Bruno cómo son estas
relaciones qué tanto depende la Unión
Europea de las importaciones y las
exportaciones desde y hacia china sobre
todo con elementos por ejemplo como el
litio que según fonderlay en Europa
dependen un 98% de las importaciones
chinas
es así como decís hablabas al principio
en tu introducción sobre la lucha contra
el cambio climático y lo cierto Es que
la mayor parte de la Revolución en
energías renovables está armada y
ensamblada con productos chinos las
baterías de litio tesla acaba de
anunciar que va a construir una nueva
fábrica de baterías de litio en Shanghai
china sigue siendo de alguna manera la
fábrica del mundo y sobre todo la
fábrica en elementos cada vez más
avanzados del punto de vista tecnológico
ya no son industrias pesadas solamente
sino que estamos hablando de Microchips
estamos hablando de baterías de litio
estamos hablando de paneles solares
y aparte china a pesar de que ya no es
el es ahora el segundo país más poblado
del mundo sigue siendo el primer mercado
del mundo no hay en ese sentido
crecimiento Industrial europeo posible
sin acceso
mercado chino con lo cual el balance que
tiene que hacer las autoridades tanto
nacionales europeas como las propias
autoridades europeas en Bruselas es
delicado porque como decía Patricio lo
económico y lo estratégico de alguna
manera tiran para lados distintos y la
relación de Europa con china es de
profunda interdependencia
Estados Unidos ha intentado y sigue
intentando una especie de desacople
entre su economía y la economía de China
pero para Europa Esto va a ser bastante
más complicado por las características
de de la propia Europa por las
características de la industria europea
que está muy especializada en ciertos
sectores y le va a ser muy difícil a
Europa reemplazar lo que recibe de China
y sobre todo reemplazar al mercado chino
con lo cual bonder Legend en ese sentido
fue muy clara nosotros no aspiramos dijo
a desacoplarnos de la economía china
sino que buscamos tener más resiliencia
eso puede significar por ejemplo Buscar
mercados alternativos puede ser en
África en el sudeste asiático pero En
definitiva reemplazar a China Como
aspiran algunos políticos en Estados
Unidos para Europa me parece que es algo
imposible y me parece que tanto macrón
como wonderlayer saben esto y eso se
reflejó en sus discursos y en su actitud
en la visita y ahí entonces vemos
claramente que China tiene una carta muy
poderosa en lo económico en lo que usted
nos explica esta profunda
interdependencia entre Europa y China
pero a cambio entonces Beijing puede
utilizar esta carta para presionar al
bloque de los 27 a que políticamente se
aleje de Estados Unidos y rompa un poco
esa relación que ha afianzado durante la
Guerra en Ucrania le pregunto Patricio
Bueno uno puede verlo como presión como
influencia hay matices hay que ver cada
relación en algunos casos uno puede
decir que sí que efectivamente hay
presiones que son mucho más tangibles y
constatables pero En definitiva lo que
china quiere es seguir profundizando sus
vínculos económicos con la Unión Europea
recordemos que antes de la pandemia vino
la pandemia después la guerra en Ucrania
queda ahí trunco o a media a medio de
digamos firmarse a poco tiempo de
firmarse un gran acuerdo de inversiones
entre la Unión Europea y China que eso
es un poco lo que quiere reactivar el
presidente si ahora quiere seguir
profundizando esos vínculos pero también
quiere estabilizar la relación con
Estados Unidos Estados Unidos sigue
siendo el principal socio comercial de
china en lo que es la mayor relación
económica por volumen que hubo en la
historia y eso también es una prioridad
ahora como decía Bruno vuelve a mezclar
a lo estratégico Y esto no es tan fácil
y aparece la cuestión de la guerra en
Ucrania donde China tiene una postura
que es diferente a la de Estados Unidos
Estados Unidos ha sido claro últimamente
ha dicho Putin debe ser Derrotado no la
guerra la tiene que ganar Ucrania y
China está diciendo queremos una salida
negociada y pacífica y que esto termine
cuanto antes por supuesto también Eso
incluye si se puede que no colapse el
régimen de Putin pero lo prioritario es
la salida de la guerra y ahí queda
Europa también en el medio no y ahí
también tendríamos que analizar los
matices entre los distintos países
porque no todos los miembros de la Unión
Europea piensan lo mismo en este sentido
y de hecho esa división se mostró
claramente en las posturas de Wonder
Legend y macron que macron estaba
impulsando al presidente chino a que
utilizara lo que él mismo denominó como
una amistad sin límites con Rusia e
intercediera con Putin para frenar a
través de la negociación la guerra en
Ucrania sin embargo
fue un poco más dura y un poco más
reticente frente a la postura y a la
cercanía de los europeos con china Bruno
Le quiero preguntar al respecto si esto
fue entonces una pérdida Por decirlo así
del viaje de los europeos a China porque
intercedían o querían que china
intercediese en la guerra en Ucrania y
al final no habló al respecto
no yo creo que macron en ese sentido
está jugando un juego de más largo plazo
la primera prioridad diría es evitar un
alineamiento completo de china con Rusia
por ejemplo mediante la venta de
armamento lo cual Sí sería un problema
para la posición de Ucrania y por lo
tanto de los europeos Me parece que
macron en ese sentido continuó una línea
tradicional de la diplomacia francesa
incluso durante la Guerra Fría de
Independencia y autonomía sin estar sin
ser equidistante sí mantener una
posición Autónoma y en lo posible
reforzar las capacidades europeas en
defensa reforzar el gasto militar
europeo y tener una perspectiva
geopolítica propia para Europa esto es
una postura de macron que no es nueva
que ya ha tenido incluso antes de la
guerra en Ucrania Pero por supuesto
macron es el presidente de Francia y la
Unión Europea son 27 países no está no
hay muchos países
no comparten la posición de macron creen
que la presencia de los Estados Unidos
las garantías de seguridad de los
Estados Unidos a través de la otan son
fundamentales y no están dispuestos a
arriesgar esa garantía buscando
autonomía de los Estados Unidos frente a
China en ese sentido dentro de la Unión
Europea como siempre hay distintas
perspectivas va a tener que haber
negociaciones y macron siendo el
presidente de Francia tiene la libertad
de expresar algunas ideas y de impulsar
algunas ideas que por supuesto la la
presidenta de la comisión de la Unión
Europea no tiene y usted hablaba que la
Unión Europea quiere evitar que haya un
alineamiento entre China y Rusia y puso
la venta de armas de parte de beijinas y
a Moscú como uno de los ítems que es lo
que Estados Unidos ha advertido durante
mucho tiempo que podría llegar a pasar
Patricia Usted cree que china le podría
vender armas a Rusia y sobre todo que
gana china por
acercarse a un país que en este momento
está ampliamente sancionado por
occidente y altamente criticado como
Rusia
a ver Acá hay que separar lo que es la
alianza estratégica entre China y Rusia
que incluso un evento tan disruptivo
como la guerra en Ucrania no puso en
riesgo sino que todo lo contrario
profundizó por supuesto podríamos hablar
mucho más en beneficios de China que de
Rusia en esta nueva ecuación Pero eso
por un lado esa Alianza va mucho más
allá de este conflicto en particular Y
probablemente lo sobreviva ahora bien
china no tiene nada para ganar
vendiéndole armas o incluso triangulando
a través de otros países como también se
ha especulado todo lo contrario china en
este momento no estaría en condiciones
de soportar el peso de las sanciones
económicas y el peso en términos de daño
de las relaciones diplomáticas que
tendría por ejemplo con la Unión Europea
No todo lo que estamos diciendo que
china quiere trabajar para preservar y
profundizar todo eso Quedaría muy muy
perjudicado a raíz de una posible venta
de armas a Rusia además cierro con esto
algo china puede darle un montón de
armamento convencional incluso de Última
Generación como tiene China en este
momento ahora los principales analistas
militares dicen que eso ni siquiera eso
podría cambiar la ecuación de la guerra
y de hecho incentivaría que lo tan
participe mucho más eh Y generando una
escalada que podría ser ya peligrosísima
ya estamos en una situación Por supuesto
muy crítica para china esto de ningún
punto de vista que lo veamos puede ser
positivo Yo creo que si esto sucediese
sería muy difícil explicar desde el
racional de Sí y de la diplomacia china
en general y si no también ha sido
bastante renuente a el fortalecimiento
de la otan y cómo ha revivido esta
organización Armada con la guerra en
Ucrania por el otro lado
firmó un documento de 51 puntos trazando
una estrategia militar Y estrechar estos
lazos con Francia Pero bueno lo quiero
preguntar si esto puede entenderse
Entonces como un nuevo capítulo militar
en la unión entre la Unión Europea y
China
No para nada yo creo que la Unión
Europea y Francia están totalmente
comprometidas con la otan Eso no
significa que Francia en lo principal
vaya a estar totalmente alineada con los
Estados Unidos por ejemplo respecto a
Taiwán no el acuerdo y la unión
de la otan frente a Ucrania no implica
que la otan vaya a convertirse en una
especie de Alianza militar anti China de
hecho la situación en el Pacífico sigue
siendo muy compleja recordemos que
Francia tenía este acuerdo para
proveerle submarinos Australia que se se
canceló y se reemplazó por un nuevo
acuerdo entre Australia Estados Unidos y
el Reino Unido Francia tiene una
presencia Autónoma en el Pacífico
histórica y presencia territorial en ese
océano Entonces no se puede me parece
trasladar el escenario europeo que es un
legado de la guerra fría y con bloques
muy concretos y con una alianza militar
muy institucionalizada a la Asia Asia Me
parece que hacia Pacífico es una región
mucho más fluida donde las tensiones
están subiendo donde hay una especie de
alineamiento y acercamiento de Estados
Unidos a países como India y Japón que
china considera está diseñada para
contener la china en Asia pero me parece
que todavía falta mucho para aventurar
una especie de otan en el Pacífico
Sí usted menciona reiteradamente la
presencia Autónoma o la autonomía que
defiende la Unión Europea y esto en
términos políticos lo vemos como
Bruselas intentan relacionarse a la vez
con china sin perder sus vínculos con
Estados Unidos esto trasladado al
escenario militar significaría que la
Unión Europea podría abstenerse ante un
eventual conflicto en Taiwán o por
ejemplo no aliarse con los
estadounidenses en su lucha por el lindo
Pacífico usted qué piensa Patricio
Bueno yo pienso que eso sería lo que
desearían si eso Si eso sucede no lo que
se harían la mayor parte de los miembros
ahora bien
en los hechos creo que se que sería muy
difícil sostener una neutralidad o
alguna posición de tipo ambigua sobre
todo porque ya sabemos que si llega a
estallar Ojalá que nunca suceda porque
sería infinitamente más grave que lo que
está sucediendo en Ucrania habría algún
involucramiento directo de los Estados
Unidos el mismo presidente biden ya lo
ha dicho y de países como Japón y otros
aliados muy cercanos con lo cual la
Unión Europea quedaría una situación muy
delicada donde sería muy difícil
mantener una neutralidad sobre todo por
por lo que dicen la misma carta de la
otan y de otras organizaciones por
supuesto mismo de la Unión Europea donde
hay un compromiso sobre esos principios
Así que creo que sería una situación muy
delicada la el deseo sería la
neutralidad pero no creo que eso pueda
ser sostenible si se da un evento
militar en relación a Taiwán claro un
deseo de neutralidad entonces difícil
de cumplirse por todos los compromisos
que ya la Unión Europea tiene con
organismos como la otan Bruno usted qué
piensa al respecto de esta posición
ambigua de la Unión Europea en lo
militar frente a la disputa entre
Estados Unidos y China qué pasa con
Bruselas sigue entre la espada y la
pared
creo complementando coincido con lo que
dice Patricio totalmente complementando
con eso también va a depender de qué
tipo si llega a ver y ojalá que no lo
haya Qué tipo de conflicto estamos
hablando alrededor de Taiwán en estos
días como reflejado tu introducción
china ha hecho simulacros de bloqueo
hacia Taiwán no eso sería una escalada
militar si eso sucediese sería una
escalada muy importante No
necesariamente un conflicto directo
vimos por ejemplo al presidente macron
viajando justo antes momentos antes de
la invasión de Rusia Ucrania intentando
una especie de acuerdo de Paz Va a haber
probablemente dependiendo del nivel de
escaladas estamos ante una guerra total
entre China y los Estados Unidos creo
como dice Patricio Europa no va a poder
mantenerse neutral y no está en el
interés europeo hacerlo Pero a medida
que van aumentando las tensiones creo
que lo que está intentando Francia y en
cierta medida la Unión Europea es
mantenerse
los canales abiertos tanto en Medellín
como Washington para en lo posible
contribuir a rebajar tensiones si esto
va a ser posible o no Si Europa va a ser
escuchada en Washington y en Beijing no
lo sabemos pero me parece que el rol que
están buscando es ese no
ser neutrales en caso de conflicto sino
hacer todo lo posible porque las
tensiones en aumento entre los Estados
Unidos de China No se salgan de cauce
para llegar a un conflicto Patricio y le
quiero preguntar en este intención de
mantener los canales abiertos como nos
dice Bruno Cuál es la postura o qué
significa la postura de personajes como
Wonder Legends que son mucho más
conservadores apoyan claramente a la
otan a su Alianza con Estados Unidos
dentro del bloque de los 27 hay una
Clara división con un macrón liderando
más por acercarse a Beijing pero con una
ley bastante reticente al respecto qué
implica Esta división dentro de la Unión
Europea frente a las relaciones con
China
bueno primero que es una división
clarísima yo mencionaba lo que fue el
viaje de joels incluso exhibiendo más
pragmatismo todavía que el propio macron
que seguramente se vio Incluso un poco
acotado por estar acompañado en esta
gira por wonderlayer no pero George
viajó solo y básicamente se enfocó en
Cómo profundizar Cómo mantener el
digamos el balance comercial que hay
actual como ampliar el volumen de
comercio cómo hacer que las automotrices
alemanas puedan vender más autos a
digamos a China y un poco lo de hervas
que fue la empresa más importante en
esta gira de macron Cómo vender más
aviones
las agendas económicas de las dos
principales economías de la Unión
Europea Alemania y Francia van por un
lado y el discurso político los
intereses
estratégicos que representa wonderlayer
en ese cargo van por otro y
probablemente esa disociación va a ir
creciendo
el correr de los meses
independientemente del curso de la
guerra en Ucrania porque no olvidemos
que previo a esto tenemos el impacto de
la pandemia que ha debilitado golpeado
fuertemente a las economías europeas y
la pandemia más las distorsiones que
está generando la guerra en Ucrania han
debilitado y han generado algún grado
obviamente Bruno lo está bien me parece
interdependencia el concepto han
profundizado el interdependencia no para
no tener que decir han profundizado la
dependencia de estas economías con
respecto a China que es un poco lo que
ha sucedido claro y usted nos hablaba de
un punto muy interesante y es como la
economía va por un lado y la política
por el otro y en ese lado de la economía
firmaron 36 documentos entre compañías
francesas y chinas Durante este viaje y
como usted lo mencionó airbag que es la
gran productora de aviones y es francesa
acordó duplicar su producción de
aeronaves en territorio Chino lo cual
claramente es un gran éxito pero por el
otro lado y que fue un poco la postura
de bonder Legend es insistir en las
presuntas violaciones de Derechos
Humanos que se cometen en China por
ejemplo con sus amenazas militares a
Taiwán con la represión en las protestas
en Hong Kong y también el trabajo
forzoso contra las minorías musulmanes
de los huigures en Shin yang Bruno Le
quiero preguntar está la Unión Europea
en posición de exigirle a China Que
respete los derechos humanos y como
intercede esto con la política y la
economía
si está en la posición de exigirlo la
respuesta es no lo que sí la Unión
Europea se precia de tener una posición
en el mundo como una superpotencia
basada en valores o Esa fue la posición
histórica de Europa con lo cual Es
lógico que Wonder Legend exprese su
preocupación sobre estos temas
claramente estos temas no están en el
centro de la agenda o la visita nos
hubiese producido Me parece que en ese
sentido prima el pragmatismo tanto como
en otros tantos países en su política
exterior un detalle que quería agregar
sobre la separación un poco de lo
económico y lo estratégico es que en lo
económico también hay competencia entre
Europa y los Estados Unidos Estuvimos
viendo en los últimos meses un intento
de Europa por establecer una política
Industrial europea con subsidios y apoyo
directo a por ejemplo las Industrias
verdes en respuesta a la ley de
reducción de la inflación de los Estados
Unidos que en realidad es una de
subsidios masivos y de política
industrial y de proteccionismo también
por parte de los Estados Unidos con lo
cual
Europa también tiene a medida que se
acerca a China también tiene sus
problemas y sus diferencias con Estados
Unidos a pesar de la lineamiento
estratégico tiene sus diferencias
económicas también con Estados Unidos y
más allá de estos acercamientos usted
nos hablaba como de la idea que ha
defendido la Unión Europea que es basada
en los valores y sobre todo las banderas
del bloque de los 27 han estado muy
centradas uno en los derechos humanos y
dos en el medio ambiente sin embargo
china está liderando que haya un nuevo
orden mundial y por eso se estaba
acercando a otros países por ejemplo
como Rusia India Irán en ese cambio de
orden mundial Le quiero preguntar a
usted Bruno es posible que china tome el
liderazgo de aquí a 2050 como Beijing se
lo propone Y si eso se logra cambiarían
Entonces estos Pilares que defienden la
Unión Europea como centros de la
política internacional
una cosa me parece que es el pbi y el
tamaño de la economía en ese sentido
china parece estar encaminándose a ser
la primera Economía del mundo en algún
momento de este siglo otra cosa distinta
es el liderazgo de como decía su nuevo
orden internacional no tengo Claro que
ese sea el objetivo de China pero
tampoco tengo Claro que china tenga la
capacidad no solamente se necesita poder
económico poder militar también se
necesita persuasión apoyos poder blando
atracción cultural
entonces no es tan fácil No es solamente
el tamaño económico militar lo que
determina el liderazgo y en ese sentido
china ha tenido problemas para construir
un liderazgo sobre todo con las grandes
potencias sobre todo con Europa mientras
que ha sido relativamente más exitoso
por ejemplo en países en desarrollo con
sus programas de de inversión comercio
el
papel etcétera entonces es más complejo
me parece simplemente que esperar a que
china crezca para automáticamente
convertirse en líder
Patricio y cuál es su postura al
respecto podría convertirse china en el
líder y qué implicaría esto para la
geopolítica internacional
bueno a ver Acá hay algunas novedades
que tienen que ver con las
características únicas que tiene China
una cultura milenaria muy particular un
país que ya fue la primera economía
mundial siglos atrás y que ahora
simplemente reclama lo que reclaman
todas las grandes potencias cuando
llegan a esa posición yo lo que tengo
dudas es porque por lo menos no está
expresado en la narrativa china ni
tampoco lo veo en las acciones es la
búsqueda de crear un nuevo orden mundial
no como dice un poco la diplomacia
estadounidense en en sus discursos Me
parece que lo que china Busca es más
representatividad Es lógico y que este
orden actual esté un poco más moldeado
en función de los intereses de China
como lo han hecho repito otras potencias
a lo largo de la historia esto por
supuesto genera Igualmente tensiones
aunque no sea un cambio profundo del
orden que es un orden de hecho con el
que china se ha beneficiado y en el cual
en los últimos 40 40 años Ha logrado un
desarrollo económico espectacular bueno
Igualmente Esto va a generar tensiones y
realineamientos lo estamos viendo en el
brix lo estamos viendo con la
revalorización de la Organización de
cooperación de Shanghai hay nuevos
bloques donde china es protagonista que
están teniendo más importancia que años
atrás y entran en tensión en algunos
aspectos con la agenda de lotan y de
otros organismos Esto no es novedoso no
debiera asustarnos lo que debiera
preocupar es cuando estas tensiones no
se pueden resolver por los canales
diplomáticos como ya hemos visto en
algunos ejemplos y en esa reorganización
ya hemos hablado de Cuál sería la
postura de la Unión Europea de Estados
Unidos y por supuesto de China usted
Menciona los bricks que es un es un tema
que usted ha estudiado bastante Cuál
sería la postura de estas naciones
emergentes sobre todo de la
latinoamericana Brasil
bueno en el caso del brix yo y lo que
veo es una confluencia cada vez más
visible de ciertos intereses económicos
ya estaban plasmados desde el inicio
mismo del brix es un poco el espíritu
fundacional de esto no las economías del
sur global emergentes sí que tienen
ciertas características
comunes en escala en las cosas que
producen y en las aspiraciones que
tienen pero ahora entran a jugar algunos
otros factores geopolíticos china le
está imprimiendo a esto más contenido y
se están acercando otras potencias
medias como Arabia Saudita podemos
mencionar el caso de México también que
está ahí en lista de espera para
ingresar estas organizaciones ya no solo
representan esos intereses fundacionales
sino que ahora quieren ampliarse quieren
lograr más número más volumen y tienen
un contenido que incluye otros temas que
van más allá de lo económico yo la
tendencia que veo es que esto siga
ganando espacio que estas organizaciones
sigan volúmenes y sigan ganando espacio
Por ejemplo si tenemos que hacer un
balance de qué va a ser más importante
este año la Cumbre del g20 o las cumbres
del otan y de la Organización de
cooperación de Shanghai si querés
también sumamos al brix va a ver que me
parece que la agenda va a ser mucho más
importante en estos últimos casos que en
la del g20 donde va a haber ausencias
divisiones cada vez más marcadas
problemas para generar un comunicado Me
parece que esa es la tendencia Bruno
usted coincide con este punto de
Patricio en que claramente estas
reuniones del sur global van a ser más
determinantes que la del misma g20
creo que como bien describe Patricio
estamos yendo no Hacia El reemplazo del
orden internacional liderado por Estados
Unidos y si se quiere Europa por un
nuevo orden internacional liderado por
china sino que estamos yendo hacia un
sistema internacional más fragmentado a
un sistema internacional donde ya el
poder está mucho más distribuido que en
la posguerra fría y eso naturalmente
genera enfrentamientos genera tensiones
genera conflictos porque se trata de un
periodo de transición de transición de
poder de transición de valores de
transición de liderazgos muy complejo
los bricks pueden jugar un rol también
es cierto que hay bastantes diferencias
entre los brics no India por ejemplo en
términos militares cada vez más cercana
a los Estados Unidos y con diferencias e
incluso territoriales con china que han
llevado a ciertos conflictos en la
frontera con lo cual tampoco es que los
brics actúan en el concierto
internacional de manera unánime también
hay matices Dentro de este grupo no
Y en este sistema internacional más
fragmentado al que vamos a atender según
usted nos dice Cuál sería entonces la
ganancia que tiene la Unión Europea al
acercarse a China ya para ir cerrando
nuestro debate su conclusión Bruno
Me parece que Europa lo que aspira es a
no depender exclusivamente de las
posiciones de los Estados Unidos
claramente en Washington hay un consenso
bipartidista alrededor de una especie de
recreación de la guerra fría y de una
estrategia de contención de China Europa
Me parece que a lo que aspira es a
mantener los canales abiertos como decía
a no alinearse automáticamente a la
posición de los Estados Unidos y a
mantener una postura que defienda los
intereses europeos en materia económica
que no siempre se aliñan los Estados
Unidos y mantener una posición sin ser
equidistante sin abandonar la alianza
militar con los Estados Unidos una
posición mucho más moderada en cuanto a
las relaciones con China de manera más
amplia Gracias Bruno y Patricio Cuál es
su conclusión frente a este acercamiento
de Bruselas hacia Beijing en este nuevo
en esta nueva reorganización del sistema
internacional
yo cerraría diciendo que él desacople es
una idea exclusiva de la política
exterior estadounidense los líderes
europeos esto lo tienen muy claro y me
parece muy prudente las posiciones que
están exhibiendo y el desacople incluso
es impracticable para los Estados Unidos
Esto se está viendo en los hechos no
Pese a que la diplomacia de biden
prácticamente a ratificado la línea de
Trump incluso la profundizado Me parece
que la línea más prudente inteligente
justamente el rumbo más pragmático que
quieren imprimirle macron sholls y otros
referentes de la Unión Europea en este
momento Patricio yustó Gracias por
acompañarnos ustedes director del
observatorio sino argentino como ya lo
habíamos dicho y también le agradezco a
Bruno vinetti por su participación él es
investigador para diálogo interamericano
sobre china analizamos entonces todas
estas posturas de Washington Bruselas y
Beijing en este nuevo sistema
internacional o cómo se está
reorganizando gracias a ustedes por
todas sus comentarios y su participación
y a ustedes quien nos sintonizan en
France 24 Gracias por elegirnos En
nombre del equipo técnico Les
agradecemos su sintonía la producción de
este programa estuvo a cargo de Laura
garzón y Andrés doncell y la producción
de los invitados la tuvo Tania Herrera
Pueden seguir dejando todos sus
comentarios y preguntas en nuestras
redes sociales y sigan conectados con
France 24 porque en minutos tenemos más
contenido internacional
[Música]